[Music]
you may have seen this story well may
you probably didn't see this story
because you're you're an intelligent
person who doesn't watch cnn all the
time but cnn viewers may have may have
heard this story
a single mother of three
faced eviction unless the the eviction
moratorium
could could have gone back into effect
and been extended and her name was dasha
kelly and cnn sent a reporter nick watt
to kelly's home they did a tour they
promoted kelly's gofundme page the
single mother of three
representative corey bush
pushed this story from seeing the single
mother of three unless the democrat
policy is extended
it was just all a lie
the woman
is not a single mother of three
she's not single
she's not a mother of anybody it turns
out
she's dating a guy who has three kids
with another woman she doesn't even live
with the guy
and i guess she knows the kids but the
kids don't live with her it was all
completely made up
it was a fiction
to push a narrative and cnn will not
face any consequences from this
and probably this woman won't face any
she'll probably just walk away with the
money
and
nobody will and it won't matter and we
can expose the lies and they'll still
have the power and they'll still have
the power people people are getting sick
of it i think
people people want to push back against
that people don't like it but when will
we be able to grab the power when will
we be able to wield that power because
right now a handful of people are
exercising all of that here in the
united states and they're trying to make
it harder and harder to oust them from
office time maybe running out to do so
it's time for the chet hanks's of the
world
to continue to speak up it's time to
speak in plain language about the rife
the rank corruption all around us i'm
glad you liked that clip we got a whole
episode it's called sleazy democrat
gives the kiss of death you can get it
on youtube but you can also get it at
apple podcasts spotify google play and
stitcher head on over there right now
and subscribe to the michael knowles
show i'll wait
thanks for subscribing we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you